turning now to an excitable bird many
families know well in 2003 author Mo
Willems debuted the Pigeon in Don't Let
the Pigeon Drive the Bus it later
starred in an animated TV version of the
book take a look
hey
can I drive the bus
please
I'll be careful since that first book
the pigeon has taken flight and seven
other Adventures the book has sold more
than six million copies in North America
alone now there's a 20th anniversary
edition of the award-winning don't Let
the Pigeon Drive the Bus that comes with
a special board game Williams is also
out with be the bus the lost and
profound wisdom of the pigeon his first
humor book for adults Mo Willems joins
us right now good morning how you doing
I'm very well I'm very happy to be here
of course so so what made you make that
turn from going from a kid's book to an
adult book that is an interesting
question you know the pigeon just
discovered that he's in books for 20
years and has never gotten to do either
I love the idea that we're talking about
the pigeons absolutely yes and so then
the pigeon discovered not only that he
was in books but that people were
laughing at him while he wasn't getting
to drive the bus or eat the cookie or
finish the hot dog so he decided to
write his own book so for be the boss
I'm just a translator I got of the
pigeon's wisdoms pigeon gives a lot of
great advice in that for all of us um
but let me read going back to the
original the kids version when you first
uh created the pigeon back in 2003 the
words used to describe him crafty
frustrated a conniver a koi conniver why
do you think readers young and old
though have embraced this crazy yelling
pigeon I yeah I don't know I think what
I try to do is I always think of my
audience but I never think for my
audience yeah so I made sure that the
pigeon was simple enough for a
five-year-old to be able to draw so that
they instead of just reading the books
or playing the books you know a book
should be a spark to creativity it
should be an opportunity to say I could
do that right or what would it be like
if I did that or how can I create my own
narrative so all of these books are
really formats don't Let the Pigeon
Drive the blank oh could come up with a
version of that and then kids are
authors and illustrators at the same
time but it took how many rejections
before you got to the point where the
question became a famous celebrity
pigeon that we now know I tend to
exaggerate so I'm going to cut the
number in half we went to 43 billion
Publishers okay and they all said the
same thing 43 billion 43 billion yeah
and they all said the same thing it's
unusual and then there was one publisher
who said it's unusual but unusual is not
a pejorative so I got the same reaction
from the rejections as I got from the
acceptance but one of the things I don't
know if you're aware of this but some
scientists have actually done studies
and they used your pigeon as the basis
for the study saying yes let the pigeon
drive the bus because they've discovered
that pigeons can figure out the shortest
route to any location I actually did
know that which is amazing isn't that
amazing yes although I think the quest
question of insurance hasn't quite
figured out by those scientists once
they get that I think we're set some of
the pigeons advice and wisdom in the
adult version be the boss
is you know a little bit questionable
one of the it's better to say I love you
more than ever of course rather than say
I used to love you less yes so what have
you learned I mean that seems like a
given but what have you learned from the
the pigeon himself I think the great
thing for me in my experience of the
pigeon has been watching kids create
their own narratives and seeing what
matters to them you know early on I got
a version of it from the kid called uh
don't let the pigeon operate the
catapults which I just loved yeah you
know yeah and again for me I am more
excited about what happens after the
book is done these kids are drawing and
they're drawing with their parents and
they're creating together so to be able
to be a spark and be part of that pretty
intimate thing you know it's bedtime
story all of that to be part of that
experience is yeah it's incredibly
fulfilling I think you were going to put
me to the test this morning yes speaking
of everybody can do this that's right I
want to see you okay also your wife is
here taking pictures and I hope you
don't use that line I used to love you
less
these lessons are hard ones
are very very hard one I think she's the
one dictating the lessons to you right
absolutely got here with this doodle
list okay so I'm often asked how do I
get my kids to be creative how do I get
my kids to draw and the answer is you
draw you be creative because as a parent
you forget how cool you are so we have a
little game okay right okay all right so
one of the fun things is that to do
things together so I'm going to get you
to make just a random Mark okay and I'm
going to try and turn that into a
drawing so you're going to make art out
of my heart
it's been nice
oh my goodness
turn that into a drawing this is why we
love you
so creative oh this is fantastic and we
got a little like I planned that like a
little froggy dinosaur
this is not my favorite time of day just
to let you guys know wow that is amazing
awesome see instead of dropping the mic
just drop the pin yeah
because that was pretty good thank you
so much
in the 20th anniversary edition of don't
Let the Pigeon Drive the Bus and the
brand new book be the bus they go on
sale tomorrow right now though time for
a check of your local weather